This simple-looking blob is actually a swarm
of millions of magnetic nanoparticles.
The swarm is controlled by a rapidly-oscillating
magnetic field.
Modifying the magnetic field allows the ‘microswarm’
to move about.
It can also change direction and shape, split
up, rejoin, and even move through a maze.
The idea is to imitate the swarms found in
nature,
in animals like birds or fish.
These groups of individuals together form
large shapes, but they're much more flexible
than a single large creature would be.
The same can be said of the microswarm.
It’s strong enough to manipulate small objects,
but flexible enough to fit through narrow spaces.
This technology may have medical applications
– perhaps delivering drugs around the body
or acting as a contrast agent for X-rays or
ultrasound scans.
But although this microswarm is pretty good
at getting through a simple maze,
the inside of the human body is a much tougher challenge.
Tricky obstacles like fast flowing blood cells
and highly salty solutions can complicate things.
So a lot more work is needed before magnetic nanoparticles
can start swarming around inside your body.